sunday evening in beijing and huang
chong wants to play a video game
but she can't by government decree
new rules in china mean that under 18s
are only allowed to play three hours of
online games per week at specified times
8 to 9 pm on fridays saturdays and
sundays
i think the ban for miners is like
banning smoking drinking and playing my
young for adults my friends send me
messages to complain about the ban
that they only have fridays and weekends
to play one hour and that they couldn't
socialise with their e-gaming friends
the rules have been introduced to curb
video gaming addiction
huang chong says she doesn't have a
problem with gaming her father disagrees
and is thankful for the state's
intervention
eventually i tried to persuade her to
give up the phone but when she's already
lost in it she feels happy
as parents we need help from the outside
from teachers from government policies
but video games are just one part of a
new campaign by the chinese communist
party to reassert its dominance over
culture and society
the perceived hedonism of the last 20
years you could also call it letting
people do what they want is being
replaced by an emphasis on proper
socialist values
film stars have been berated by the
government for promoting what they call
fake ugly and evil values
and the country's tv regulator has
banned what it calls effeminate men from
appearing on screens
using the offensive term [ __ ] boys to
describe them in its official
announcement
activist lou reyes group gives
information and support to parents whose
children have come out as gay
many people use [ __ ] boys as an
aggressive and derogatory word to label
people who are not heterosexual or do
not have the typical and traditional sex
relations and i think the policy
negatively affects the young lgbt people
who haven't come out yet
it is an all-out effort by the party to
reshape culture and society in its own
image
back in beijing government sanctioned
playtime is over
but there are ways around the system
many people use adults phones to log
into games but we're smarter we climb
over the firewall it takes risk to climb
over the firewall and it's illegal few
people succeed
teenagers now find themselves in a
skirmish against the state
and knowing teenagers you wouldn't
necessarily bet on the state to win
tom cheshire sky news shanghai